you are 1 sweet
smart girl or you are very helpful
white girls
get in their primary school report
more often such compliments than boys
or children with 1 migration background
this is evident from research by the University of Leiden
where antoinette cooperates
we ended up looking at 247 reports
from all different schools
all different teachers
they were looking at comments
who wrote teachers and masters to reports
and saw clear differences in it
i Am white girls saw so many comments
if you are sweet
you are nice
and 1 report of 1 boy with migratieachtergronden
more stayed somewhere that was anyway at Elk
box negative
comments stood
and then there was visual education
the only subject where there was something positive
but then it said yes again
but you could do your best
so the positive things also became negative
and comments like that
can affect it
self-confidence of students
she says teachers can pay attention to it
when they write reports
at teacher training
they could also pay attention to that
but it is also about
teachers talk to their students every day
and those reports
you usually only have them twice a year
it is also about teachers doing their
deliver everyday interactions